what's a god they were real if you
believe in them who you you wouldn't
believe in me if I told you this is my
man shadow moon
he does not know Otherworld amazing Amen
you've gotten yourself mixed up in some
really weird [ __ ] shadow it was
forgotten unloved as any of us
I'm doing just fine we tried to start a
war world war already and we're losing
who's happier times they are changing we
need you to fight them to show them who
we are what's the plan whoa he isn't he
do you ever need none of this feels
really feels like a dream and things are
never going back to the way that they
work it will be grow nice win or lose
you have died mrs. Padilla and it is
time for you to come with me oh my baby
at the aisle the Potter will do shuttle
this way when we first meet shadow he's
in prison and the warden bring them into
his office and reveals that his wife was
in an accident
good news relating under me bad news mr.
vice chair
shadow is broken his life is falling
apart and then he meets a mysterious old
hustler who calls himself Wednesday who
offers him a job I just happen to be in
a hiring position and I could be mr.
Wednesday with a shake of their hand
Shadowmoon thought he knew how the world
worked but he comes to me mr. Wednesday
and finds out that God exists and they
are walking around the earth with us and
composing the mind that our biggest
sacrifices one might be asked to make
than going a little mad there's a storm
brewing between the new gods and the old
the power of fire is fire power the old
gods and new gods have the same power
source which is worship the biblical and
mythical gods of old have been faded out
nowadays we worship technology medium
money fame we're going to delete you one
click and you are over me without
worship and without that belief that
they get from people the gods
essentially lose all their abilities all
their standing all of their power and
can ultimately die out we need you
spring to fight them to shoulder new
guards who we are
war is coming and Wednesday and shadow
are going across America to enlist old
gods in a war against the legal as well
and that just happened it's still
happening
[Music]
see youtubers is Charlie if you didn't
know American Gods is starting tomorrow
night Simon explained what's going on
some of the broad concepts behind the
series in the characters if you never
heard of American Gods you have no idea
what it is it's based on a book written
by Neil Gaiman
and it's a little bit like Game of
Thrones if everybody on Game of Thrones
was a god like imagine the war of the
five kings if everyone were a god and
the thing that they were fighting over
was faith itself there's only so many
people in the world God's draw their
strength from worship so you see the on
crouching knew gods like media
television the internet the new gods of
the modern world supplanting the old
gods and sort of stealing the worship
from them causing them to slowly fade
away and die but depending on your guys
interest level I will do weekly episode
videos for it I'm definitely doing an
episode video tomorrow night the most
important stuff is that it's on the
Starz channel in the United States and
outside the United States is on Amazon
Prime so just double check whichever
country you live in where to find
American Gods and if you have to Loki
leech it from somewhere that we will not
judge you because it is going to be the
most hardcore new series this year I am
so excited about it they have one of the
best creative minds in television
running the show Bryan Fuller remember
when we used to be really excited about
that new Star Trek TV show because he
was running it the trailer did a pretty
good job of setting up the series the
protagonist that you follow around his
shadow moon he is the audience surrogate
the one that's learning that gods are
real oh my god what the hell is going on
there's this mystical crazy world all
around us that I never knew about so the
way they explain gods is that people
create them through their faith and they
bring them wherever they go so there's a
couple key scenes during the first
episode that explain the mechanics of
that you see slaves from Africa that
worship Anansi the trickster God being
taken to America so through their prayer
they bring the God with him so you get
to see him on the slave ship and it sort
of explains how a lot of the old gods
came to America so as the title implies
American Gods these are all old gods and
new gods they were either brought there
by immigrants from the old world
wherever they came from or their new
gods like Gillian Anderson who
represent television because people
nowadays worship television like a god
so the name of the game for these old
gods is that one you just lay down and
dies people stop worshipping you or you
can adapt to new forms of worship based
on the way people's culture and
traditions have changed probably the
best example of that in the trailer is
this God here
he's Vulcan the Roman god of fire
metalworking the Forge
volcanoes so what happened is is that
there's not a lot of volcanoes in
America the way he's adapted in the
modern world is to draw his power from
the face that people put in their guns
so a gun is kind of like a mini volcano
is a joke that they use on the show so
he's an old god adapting to new forms of
worship so part of the fun of the series
is that virtually all the characters
that shadow meets as he treks across the
land are gods in some way either old
gods or new gods
so mr. Wednesday is Odin like you
noticed the glass eye you notice their
Ravens all over the place he's a god of
death along with many other things so
part of the reason why he wants this war
with the new gods is because he draw a
strength from blood that spilled on
battlefields so part of the way that
he's trying to adapt to the modern world
is to get people to make war on each
other so it's a little bit like Ares in
the Wonder Woman movie so that's why
he's trying to sell these old gods on
this war don't go out like a [ __ ] go
out fighting don't let them take your
faith from you but he also really wants
people to die even though it could be as
friends it could be the enemies that
they're trying to take down either way
he comes out on top
so ian mcshane mr. Wednesday Odin is the
ultimate con man of the series and it is
just so fun to watch him work his magic
so just like Game of Thrones
there is symbolism in everything and
objects in turns of phrase so I'll play
this scene here between mr. Wednesday
and shadow where he's flipping a coin
my hustler swindler cheater and liar
tales it's not always going to details
the heading of that was a hatchet to mr.
Wednesday being a trickster pulling a
long con
trying to engineer this war so that he
can gain all this power the coin itself
as in coin trick coin tricks are a big
thing in American Gods is sort of a hat
tip to that as well so there's a lot
that we have to wait to talk about till
after the first episode because it's
kind of spoilery with respect to a very
special coin in mad Sweeney's character
but we can talk all about it there is
crazy symbolism so everybody is a god
even shadow moon is the god Baldur from
Norse mythology so one of his powers
even though he doesn't fully believe it
yet is a measure of indestructibility
which is why you see him getting into
that fight with Matt Sweeney mr.
Wednesday sort of goes him into it just
to see what he's made of
so as we meet new characters through the
first episode I'll point out which God
they are what their powers are and how
they fit into this series but if you
have the book or you're getting ready to
read it they said that the first season
isn't going to do the entire book
they're only going through about halfway
but because the book was published a
long time ago you could actually go on
and read what happens to the characters
learn all about them but I'll try to
explain as much as possible as we meet
them through the series but you guys can
just let me know what you want me to
focus on mostly during my videos so I
will be doing giveaways just like I do
for Game of Thrones so if you watch my
Game of Thrones videos it'll be the same
deal for this series and hopefully
everybody finds it I really wanted to be
popular creatively it's just as good but
sometimes there are a lot of outside
factors that influence how people find
TV shows like if you don't know what
channel it's on or you don't know when
it's on or there's some other big
confusion so hopefully you guys are able
to find it Sunday night is when it
starts I'll post my video after it airs
it is going to be crazy so while you
wait for that to post you can click here
for a brand new game of Thrones and you
can click here for brand new Star Wars
Episode 8 thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you